- LADIES AND GENTLEMEN,
PLEASE TURN OFF YOUR CELL PHONES
AND ENJOY OUR PRODUCTION
OF LUNCH WITH GREATNESS.
- MY, MY, MY.
WHAT A BEAUTIFUL DAY
IN MONTGOMERY, ALABAMA.
I SWEAR, THE SUN IS SO HOT,
I NEARLY MELTED.
- INDEED, DR. KING,
BUT I SUSPECT
WE DIDN'T MEET HERE
TO TALK ABOUT THE WEATHER.
- INDEED,
BROTHER MALCOLM.
UNLESS, OF COURSE,
WE ARTICULATE
THAT THE SUN
IN THIS COUNTRY
SHINES BRIGHTER ON SOME
THAN IT DOES ON OTHERS.
- MM.
- YEAH.
- YES, BUT WHEN THE SUN
DOES SHINE ON US,
IT IS GROWING
THE SEEDS OF REVOLUTION.
- AMEN.
- THAT'S WHAT I'M TALKING ABOUT.
- I SEE YOUR POINT,
BROTHER MALCOLM,
BUT DO NOT THOSE SAME SEEDS
NEED TO BE WATERED WITH LOVE?
[audience murmurs in agreement]
- I SUPPOSE THAT IS THE SUBJECT
OF SOME DISCUSSION, DR. KING.
- [coughs]
- AND I AM ALL FOR DISCUSSION,
BROTHER MALCOLM.
UNLESS, OF COURSE,
THE WORDS DEVOLVE
INTO PROCLAMATIONS
OF HATE.
- YES.
- RIGHT.
- WELL, IS THAT NOT
WHY WE ARE HERE TODAY, DR. KING,
TO DISCUSS?
[fly buzzes]
- YES, BROTHER MALCOLM.
AND I AM CONFIDENT,
THAT AS WE DISCUSS--
- WE ARE GOING TO DISCUSS IT
AND DISCUSS IT
UNTIL I SAY THAT
OUR PEOPLE
HAVE NEVER RESORTED TO VIOLENCE
BEFORE THE WHITE MAN
GAVE THEM NO CHOICE
BUT TO PAY HIM BACK
IN THE ONLY CURRENCY
HE UNDERSTANDS.
- YES.
[applause]
- BROTHER MALCOLM,
IS THAT WHAT YOU
REALLY HAVE TO SAY...
AT THIS POINT...
IN OUR LUNCH?
- INDEED, DR. KING,
BECAUSE WE DIDN'T LAND
ON PLYMOUTH ROCK.
PLYMOUTH ROCK
LANDED ON US.
[audience shouts in agreement]
- AMEN.
- MM-HMM.
- OKAY, WELL, YES.
ALL RIGHT.
YEAH, I-I'VE HEARD
YOU SAY THAT BEFORE.
I...DON'T KNOW WHY
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT ROCKS WHEN,
IN FACT,
IT IS THE FLESH AND THE BONE
AND THE--THE DREAMS--
I-I HAVE A DREAM
THAT SOMEDAY OUR CHILDREN
WILL BE JUDGED
BY THE CONTENT
OF THEIR CHARACTER,
NOT BY THE COLOR
OF THEIR SKIN.
[cheers and applause]
- SAME FOR ME.
SAME FOR ME.
IN FACT,
I BELIEVE THAT ONE DAY,
A BLACK MAN
WILL BECOME THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES
OF AMERICA.
all: YES.
- HOPEFULLY FOR EIGHT YEARS.
OBAMA 2012.
[cheers and applause]
- OH, OF COURSE, EIGHT YEARS.
OF COURSE, EIGHT YEARS.
THAT'S A GIVEN, RIGHT?
[laughs] THAT'S A GIVEN.
YOU KNOW? I MEAN,
BUT IN ORDER TO GET THERE,
ISN'T HE GOING TO NEED
THE HELP
OF OUR STRONG, BEAUTIFUL,
BLACK WOMEN?
[cheers and applause]
GOTTA RESPECT THE SISTER.
GOTTA RESPECT
THE SISTER!
GOTTA RESPECT THE SISTER.
[cheers and applause]
- AS WESLEY SNIPES SAID
IN PASSENGER 57,
"ALWAYS BET ON BLACK."
LA LA LA.
[cheers and applause]
- ♪ THE WEST SIDE
IS THE BEST SIDE ♪
[cheers and applause]